الزحف يسأل عنه بعد
يخرج أردوغان الاحتفالي
مصعد الكرملين أصر في وقت سابق
للقاء بوتين في تركيا
يستحب أن يكون ذكرا
اكرون وميركل
لكن أردوغان في موسكو يذهب طويلا
ممرات المبنى الأول للكرملين
الوفد يديره المصورون والمصورون
لالتقاط اللحظة
المصافحة بمزاج بوتين
الرئيس أردوغان يتغير كثيرا
بحدة شيء 5 يناقش العالم كله
قبل أيام قليلة دعا روسيا
ابتعد عن طريقه وعشية وصوله
الكرملين
أعرب عن أمله في أن كل شيء سينجح
تعامل الآن دعنا نرى ما سيحدث
تجري
صورة للقائد العظيم الإسكندر
سوفوروف عند مدخل مكتب التمثيل
المكتب شيء لا مفر منه
الرئيس التركي أردوغان لن يمر أحد
ربما لن يلتفت إلى هؤلاء
تفاصيل وصدف مثل هذه الصور في هذه
القاعات وعلى جدران الكرملين
منذ زمن بعيد ، لكنها كانت في أنقرة
حتى تشتت بعض المسؤولين
حتى أن تصريحاتهم العدوانية
يذكر عدد الحرب بين روسيا و
تركيا في هذه الغرفة أي أجنبي
التفويض ليس دائما لفترة طويلة
تأخر انتظار إشارة ذلك
الرئيس الروسي مستعد للقاء
وقت انتظار الوفد التركي
امتدت بودراس بشكل غير متوقع أردوغان
صامت وينظر إلى نقطة واحدة فقط
من حين لآخر ينقل بصره إلى آخر
جانب وزير الخارجية
cavusoglu يتتبع الوقت ويبدأ
انظر إلى الغرفة التي كانت فيها
كما جعل الوفد صهرها أردوغان
وزير المالية
وزير الدفاع التركي يصحح له
كما تقدر ربطة العنق ظهور الآخرين
والآن يخطو أردوغان خطوة إلى الأمام
اتخذ خطوة وراءه بحذر وبشكل غير محسوس
وبقية مساعدي أردوغان
تبقى قليلا وراء بجد
اطوي معطفه حتى لا يتجعد
وشاح أحمر أيضًا ، على ما يبدو
زعيم تركي ونوع من
صخب
الكرملين يفرض الوفد التركي
جاء بحقيبة كبيرة
ضع المستندات المهمة على كرسي قريب
على وشك الانتهاء بالفعل دقيقتان من الانتظار
هذه الغرفة
في قمرة القيادة